il était gentil avec toi tu as le mans
avait beaucoup de bière mais elle
faisait de la bonne purée beau il est où
ton papa je vais t'emmener dans un
endroit avec d'autres enfants comme toi
sans papa et sa maman je vous présente
votre nouveau camarade icare préfère
qu'on l'appelle courchesne n'a plutôt
pas d'avis attaque
six mois ça dure je rentrais chez moi
avec nan mais c'est impossible causette
elle est partie d'un malaise est tous
pareils je fume personnes brisées mais
on se lève on se la voir monsieur lol
il nous raconte l histoire d autres qui
étaient là avant nous la nouvelle
pourquoi tu essaies tu as tes ça voilà
weight a tout pigé il quelque chose pour
toi cette fille dont tu m'as parlé elle
est comment tu as mal comment n'importe
quoi mais bien sûr mais que ça se voit
des kilomètres que tu es amoureux de
camille camille doit passer le week-end
avec moi je te laisserais pas partir
viens là ma petite chérie
si on n'avait pas mené là
je trouverai jamais connu
elle restera toute la viande on sourit
et
alors super couchette c'est quoi ta
super pouvoir se poussent et légumes
plus vite
et toi te déguiser en quoi on débile
suivant suivant bonjour tu viens
t'asseoir ici a juste posé deux trois
petites questions même maguy jamais
atteint les eaux jean panier bon super
étoile dans un film away come back
ouais mais moi je sais pas j'ai pas pété
7 euros t1 de monde se fout de ma gueule
à l'école alain salas mais ça valait
bien toujours pour tous toi par exemple
sans te demander de jouer un enfant d'à
plus de parents non de plus que la
parution de divorcer bas ils s'aiment
plus pire ils ont des problèmes comme ça
et puis des fois j'ai un petit peu
triste intérieur
tu peux vous poser une question via wave
asie c'est look avait choisi l'un d'eux
projette alors non ce n'est pas moi ça
c'est dans le livre c'est sa maman dans
un livre elle appelle son garçon
projette tu vois ça ne plaît pas
courageux un corps est assez simple pour
y courir
ça fait fi à ses mates et pris dans fais
mais je peux changer de nom